the ukrainian countryside turns into  what  my now uh  past colleague who died several years  ago robert conquest called a vast belson  and by that you know the images of  bodies just lying everywhere  you know people dead  and uh  and dying  you know of hunger which is  by the way i mean  as you know i've spent a lot of time  studying genocide i don't think there's  anything worse than dying of hunger from  what i have read i mean you see terrible  ways that people die right  but dying of hunger is just such a  horrible horrible thing and so for  example  we know there were many cases of  cannibalism in the countryside because  there wasn't anything to eat people were  eating their own kids  you